all right so amber
you're back again yeah but something
happened last night right
yeah um you know i said that you know i
did
cut down my dating dramatically you know
uh but sometimes you gotta eat
you know this morning i go short on rent
you know so i had to get some rent money
so i decided to go out there put in my
best skippies i go and i wait
it doesn't take time any time at all you
know i get picked up by someone
seemed cool talking talking talking
not too many red flags you know
then uh got to the spot helping back
okay um he stepped out of the car
i'm waiting i'm waiting waiting he comes
around this side of the car
just to the back door and he opens the
back door
and you know starts immediately he just
wants me to like go to towns you know
point out
stick plenty out and i'm like oh you
know the name of bread
and then he goes what and he goes in his
pocket and he pulls out something sprays
in the page i've been straight in the
face before my mace this is not mace
this is something totally different it
was like an aerosol so it hit me here
and just hit me like a clutch
so immediately you know i'm like whoa
okay this is gonna be bad but i'm like
thinking like
we had such a cool conversation maybe i
could shit-talk them like all the other
ones you know
damn what's up with that why are you
doing that [ __ ] you know it's a big deal
you don't date no problem with the date
get on my car [ __ ] it's raising again
now the second time it's burning more
than before the first
now i know i'm in trouble start trying
to get to get out this back seat or
whatever
go to that door no handle
so made a deal with them
you let me go give me some [ __ ]
oh you're gonna give me that anyway
so dude i thought i needed you to get
out
spread me again now give me your money
[ __ ]
what money i don't have any money
that's why i came aside
one punch talking about the
truck give me money now i mind you i'm
wearing clothes that are see-through
you see that i have nothing other than
my outfit on you know i have nothing you
know
shoes are in the front seat of this car
i don't have nothing i keep telling him
i have nothing had made the money sir
kept saying sir because you know this
kid
had a southern accent he had seven charm
so i tried to
turn my back you know sir
didn't work when it came to my face was
in the gravel
there was blood all over the place and i
just went to get away from there as fast
as i could
so so when did this happen
like uh earlier this morning like it's
five o'clock this morning so five six
o'clock it wasn't like
so we're talking about five minutes it
happened in figaro
definitely have it on fake it definitely
happens one of those things you know
it's
the bad with the good so he knocked you
out
had to i don't know what he did i don't
know if it was the
stuff he sprayed on me or the punches i
took to the head
i don't know i can't remember everything
but i just remember
when i came to my face was in the gravel
and i was way far away from his car
so i don't even know how i got there i
hope i ran
right that's good what's what's going on
so you have a black eye
or oh i can't even see i lie yeah but
not just a black eye that black spirit i
knew i should have been there you know
i knew but once again your teeth are
okay
your teeth are okay oh no i got two new
broken teeth
and it's that lip salad if i if i live
this from here over i feel like i got
hit by a truck yeah your left side of
your face is messed up
here over i can see but i can't see
because whatever you spray my face
it still burns it's still burning
so once again like i said it's a work
hazard it goes with the job right
but today this one this time mark
not okay really really not okay
so i'm i'm doing it legally i'm gonna go
to the police station when i leave here
and do whatever i
can it's been it's late but i'm giving
them whatever information i can
because i want another girl to wake up
or not wake up
because of this guy or because i didn't
make effort to tell
anybody not okay and i hate to see
someone else have to go through this
so not that this is about race but just
so that people will know who we're
dealing with
it's a what race oh it's a young
young black african-american male no
with a southern accent
with a southern accent he said he's from
alabama mentioned that he was 30 years
old
has a truck that makes a lot of noise
[Music]
is also because he i had met him before
and i was supposed to date him but i
didn't
so when i saw him again it was like
familiarity hey
you know because it says cat lick your
ass
sure whatever it is your money though
but maybe that one thing that that one
phrase kind of like your ass might be
the one thing that someone hears
or that one thing about his southern
accent or his age
anything i can get out there so
girls in southern california can know
this creek there's a creepy one out
there
another creeps out there
this has happened to you before yeah
this is the worst so
i've never like really walked away hurt
like this
that's why i thought it was always no
big deal
but the this the disfigurement i saw in
the mirror
i see the way i feel and when i feel my
spirit feels
this is way to be honest it's not okay
and i'm mad
don't do somebody who are you mad at him
or yourself or
i'm at myself but
that's a daily anger i'm always fighting
myself you know
i'm at him because he could have just
asked me he'd have to physically harm me
i didn't have anything [ __ ] i would have
came up with something
my shoes were worth 200 to take them
sell them they're brand new i just want
them where it's time today
something let me help you gonna take me
my house i'll give you a couple bucks
i've done that before i had a guy put a
nightmare into my head
and i was able to talk that i mean all
the way down and convince him that you
know what you look too good you have to
break me
anytime you want to rape some girl here
you call me because i'll give it to you
[ __ ] fine tell you know so
like i said this is not okay and i'm mad
and if you go to the police would you
get in trouble
probably so probably so because
meeting when i do many where i stay just
just admitting things probably wouldn't
be the best for me
because it's you know i believe i'm
gonna get in trouble
i believe that there's gonna be
consequences for me
but i'm loving it for it's okay
i've had a nice life i mean you know had
okay life you know
yeah i like my age but that's okay
just be careful girls and parents and
people that have kids out there
it's all starts at childhood this all
starts all this trauma begins and
when you're a small kid you gotta watch
the kids gotta protect the kids
you gotta be there for the kids because
i was once a kid
inside i still feel like that 13 year
old kid kind of lived my life reckless
like that 13 year old kid
but maybe somebody protected this 13
year old kid
[ __ ] that could have been a congressman
or something you know
there's a lot of people out there like
that but can't do nothing about us
with kids we watch your kids
people watching you hate sending your
kids off with
watch out watch you protect the kids
that's like asking did you
how many times does this happen to you
ten years average four times it
thank you average six times six eight
times a year
that's how many times this happened
yeah does this make you wanna consider
like totally stopping
yeah so i haven't have a pair of so i
still have one pair
they went in the trash can this morning
all the clothes that
are associated with that lifestyle went
in trash can this morning
you see me out there on the sidewalk
it's because i'm walking to my car
amber no longer exists my name is april
and from this day forward i'm gonna be
april
good for you i'm glad you weren't
hurt any worse it's horrible but it
could have been a lot worse
yeah it could be a lot worse maybe this
maybe this is what gets you out
right and thank god school is online
classes are online it's thank god
you know all right john well thank you
for calling me thank you for the
horrible news
thank you i just wanted to make sure you
got out there and share the story i'm
glad you're okay
thank you okay thank you
you